Why are people asking for directions
Do you not have a phone, GPS, Google Maps
I don't understand
why is anybody asking for directions
not only that
if we're going out to dinner and you suggest a restaurant, location
a place and you tell me it's North, East
south or west
Don't do that
Don't
that's not gonna help me figure out where we're going
what state we are in
what country we're in
just stop, don't do it
I got GPS I can figure it out on my own
and I guarantee giving me a compass won't help me get there
We need to stop normalizing giving directions
It just makes no freeking sense in this age where everybody has one of these
one of these
make it make sense
Okay you can ask for directions if you're like a granny or a grampy
you're allowed